what have you learned about porn use
amongst young men and how they feel
about it
so I think porn use is one of the most
misunderstood things from this is just
my opinion okay from uh
clinical perspective from a
psychological perspective from a
neuroscience perspective
so
you know we've done a lot of work with
pornography usage pornography addicts so
I think the first thing to understand a
lot of interesting stuff came out from
our internal research we're hopefully
going to publish a paper on this within
the next year or so but hasn't really
been formulated yet
so the first thing that's really
interesting is that people who are
addicted to pornography oftentimes get
exposed at a very very young age we're
talking about first exposure to
pornography like prepubescent most of
the time
second thing is that pornography usage
has nothing to do with sexual perversion
so a lot of people will think if someone
is really really addicted to pornography
they must be like really horny or like
depraved in some way or things like that
generally speaking my experience has
been that pornography usage is really
just a very powerful emotional coping
mechanism
so pornography usage will suppress a lot
of negative emotions and if you talk to
people who use pornography especially in
an addictive way what leads to usage is
like feeling bad about yourself and this
is the big problem with pornography
usage which is that once you start to
use it it sort of engenders more shame
and guilt and in order to deal with the
shame and guilt you have to use it again
right and and it's just the kind of
thing where if you like think about the
societal stigma of someone's like yeah
you know like I grew up and and I was
addicted to alcohol like and now I'm
sober for 20 years and it's like good
for you man and it's like yeah I'm a
recovering pornography addict and it's
like
you know you're not going to get the
same you know if you're dating someone
and you're let's say you have his
brother or sister like yeah I'm dating
someone who's like been sober for 10
years exactly cool right like that's
probably good like not bad for your life
I'm dating someone who's like been
addicted to pornography for 10 years and
they're they're you know like
there's a lot of stigma associated with
a lot of Shame associated with it I
think it's really about emotional
regulation
this is really interesting there's
research that shows that
um so it really has nothing to do with
sex basically which is what's weird I
mean it can have sexual consequences and
stuff and create problems in
relationships but there's a research
that did a multivariate regression
analysis on people addicted to
pornography which means they looked at
which variable Associates the most with
pornography usage and the number one
variable was meaninglessness
so the more meaningless your life is the
more likely you are to be addicted to
pornography
and so what we've actually kind of found
which is really interesting is when you
work with people like that helping them
develop like purpose helps them actually
like you have to have a reason to stop
watching pornography it's got to be like
some kind of you know
you have to go through that withdrawal
for some greater good and so helping
people find purpose is like one of the
biggest things that apparently helps
with pornography
what do you think it says that porn use
doesn't seem to be
actually that massive of a sexual
trigger it doesn't seem to be triggered
all that much by it it's triggered by
things outside of
sex in a way it's triggered by life
circumstances meaninglessness yeah so so
I think it's this comes down to the
neurochemistry so if we think about
addictions
why do we get addicted to stuff because
of the effect it has on our brain and so
if we think about from an evolutionary
standpoint
there are a couple of different things
that will suppress our negative emotions
and will also give us like a rush of
like let's say euphoric
neurotransmitters so orgasm is one of
these things so why does orgasm feel
really good because it's required for
the procreation of the species right so
evolutionarily when orgasm feels really
good we're gonna have more sex and
that'll result in
the continuation of the human race the
interesting thing is if you look at
actually ancient yogic literature as
well they say that there's this you know
state of bliss called samadhi which is
sort of the purpose of meditation and
there are a couple of interesting ways
that you can get temporary samadhi and
orgasm is one of them so this also is
like one of the reasons that tantric sex
is a thing and and things like that
which is a maybe a conversation for a
different day maybe conversation for
today but I think we've known for a long
time so why is pornography like this
because orgasm has very specific
like activation within the brain and so
now if you kind of think about it let's
say I'm feeling worthless about myself
I'm not doing anything in life I'm kind
of like sitting around not doing
anything I'm tired of feeling this way
what is a switch I can flick in my brain
that lets me forget everything pushes my
negative emotions away and actually
gives me a spurt of
positive neurotransmitters which I'm not
sure exactly what happens when people
orgasm in the brain but you know and and
that's why pornography addiction exists
so it's not really about sex
that's so interesting that you have all
of these different coping mechanisms
whether it be binge eating whether it be
alcohol whether it be cannabis social
media video games porn what we what
we've done is
increase the variety of ways that you
can hide from your feelings
absolutely and pick pick your flavor of
ice cream for today
what is it going to be yeah right and
and there's there are people have drugs
of choice which may be due to some
amount of genetic vulnerability but if
you really think about it I think about
pornography addiction is the closest to
substance use because of its
hard-hitting
like a fact right so if you think about
getting high there's discrete like
chemicals that enter into your brain and
like activate certain receptors whereas
video games are like a little bit more
Global but pornography is really
especially that arousal stuff and stuff
like that is a very targeted way to
activate your brain in a particular way
more closely resembles the substance
Downstream from pornography use have you
seen sexual dysfunction is this
Associated absolutely so okay so how is
it that porn use isn't all that sexual
and yet Downstream from porn use you get
sexual dysfunction for a couple
different reasons so first let's
understand that
sexual
means multiple things within one person
so there's a physical aspect to it
there's a neuroscientific aspect to it
there's a psychological aspect to it so
one thing that you tend to see is
something that you know a term that I
coined on stream one day death grip
syndrome which is if you look at men
especially who masturbate when they use
pornography the physiologic
stimulus for lack of a better term
that men will use actually does not
approximate the
physiologic stimulus of intercourse
so to put it bluntly I'm trying to avoid
saying this but you know not using lube
and using your death grip hand feels
different from a vagina like that's just
how it works and and so what happens is
the the body can acclimatize to this
right like that's like literally what
happens so you get used to you need a
particular kind of stimuli you get
conditioned to require a certain kind of
stimulation to achieve climax
and so then sometimes what can happen
when when people engage in sexual
intercourse is that they can't get that
kind of stimulus to achieve climax
they've de-trained themselves from being
stimulated by real physiological
interaction with somebody else's body
yeah absolutely right so they also have
a very very strong grip right so so
mentally and so there's interesting
things because I've literally worked
with patients where like the process of
this is deconditioning so we'll sort of
say like you know loose grip a lot of
Loop and and that'll be frustrating for
I'm serious I'm not I'm you know I know
it's funny but like seriously because
you have to do that physiological
deconditioning and you have to try to
approximate you know things like that
and there's all kinds of stuff that you
can do with your partner and things like
that too so you can fix this
sometimes you'll see like erectile
dysfunction just kind of straight up
um and then they're also like
neuroscience and psychological impacts
right so sometimes people will have so
much shame for pornography that there's
you know they have difficulty performing
they feel so guilty uh there's all kinds
of stuff like does your partner know
that you use pornography and things like
that so that can lead to
um you know a difficulty with sort of
forming and maintaining erections which
is different from reaching orgasm
right so there's a whole physiologic
chain of things going on
and and so we'll we'll definitely see
that kind of stuff and then in some
cases what you also tend to see is that
there's this principle called online
drift on the internet where
since the goal is emotional engagement
how does a platform keep you emotionally
engaged they do it by serving up more
extreme content
so if you look at your platform
algorithms if there's certain things
that you search for it'll serve you like
tons of extreme stuff in that way
so if you watch one cute cat video then
you need to see cats doing cuter things
to stay on the platform and then cats
are doing cuter stuff and cuter stuff
and cuter stuff we see this with
pornography usage as well where there's
like a gradual like movement towards
like hardcore pornography use because
you require
more stimulus to your eyes and ears and
things like that to get that same level
of arousal and if you do that and if you
require that really high level of
stimulus
of of you know just like more brighter
bigger whatever and and then if you if
you have sexual relations with a regular
human being like the stimulus is just
different if you're not able to recreate
the zero gravity acrobatics that you've
just seen on Pawn Yeah Mary Harrington
calls that the law of FAP entropy which
is whatever you start out wanking to
will get progressively more intense over
time beautiful yeah it's it's her second
law of porno Dynamics I think actually
um I I really like the introduction of
the framing in the story that you tell
yourself around your Pawn use is
massively
contributing to what is going to happen
out the other side of it and I think
that again you know
um what would this be like if it was
easier
um what would there is a trend online at
the moment that demonizes pawn use and
it's because there is a non-zero number
of people for whom porn use is
destructive and can't control it that
has been used to cover all of ponies as
if you're using porn this makes you
susceptible to a a whole Suite of
problems that are going to occur even if
you do have a healthy relationship with
it because there are a whole host of
people that are able to use pawn and
have a healthy relationship with it and
at least not have dysfunction on the
other side of it whether it's healthy or
not maybe a little bit of a different
discussion
but for the people who see their Pawn
use as something which is worthy of
Shame which is worthy of guilt which is
worthy of making them feel like less of
a man less of a appropriate partner
I can guarantee that you are somebody
who does have a problem with ponies porn
news is not good for you if that is the
story that you tell yourself about your
porn use and it's so recursive and and
self-reinforcing it's brutal
yeah absolutely I mean I think that you
know it's interesting because when when
people sort of demonize porn use I think
I'm seeing this trend more and more
where
if something if I have a problem with
something our society is moving more and
more towards that thing needs to go away
as opposed to I need to get better at
handling it
and so the really scary cycle that I see
is that the more that we remove things
the less tolerant we become
and then smaller and smaller things can
set us off we'll get back to talking to
Dr Kane one minute but first I need to
tell you about element I've taken
element every single morning for
probably three years now it is my
favorite way to start the day it tastes
fantastic it optimizes my hydration it
makes my brain work more effectively and
it really wakes me up element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
gluten no colors no artificial
ingredients no fillers and no BS they
are the exclusive hydration partner to
Team USA weightlifting and rely down by
tons of FBI sniper teams Special Forces
Navy Seals and high performers all
around the world it plays a critical
role in reducing muscle cramps and
fatigue whilst optimizing brain health
and regulating your appetite on top of
all of that they've got a no BS no
questions asked refund policy so you can
buy it and if you do not like it for any
reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you love it head to drink
lmnt.com modernwisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face